this is our moment our Super Bowl moment
sunday brings us America's most watched
sporting event
Atlantis politicians are excited that
the world's best come to the world's
greatest stage to give us what they've
got and what will Atlanta give we'll
turn on the lights and put on a show and
pay for part of that show with their
taxpayers money hundreds of millions of
dollars which they gave to billionaire
Arthur Blank owner of Atlanta's football
team to get him to build this Stadium a
show place that Atlanta's former mayor
called simply the best facility in the
world to the people of Atlanta at least
get a cut of the restaurant and
merchandising revenue no Falcons control
all the money from parking restaurants
and merchandising sweet deals like that
are not unusual 12 teams have actually
turned a profit on stadium subsidies
alone yes they received more money than
it costs to build their facilities so
taxpayers most of whom never attend a
game subsidize billionaires seems like a
scam to me I don't fault Arthur Blank
for grabbing the money I even like the
guy blank improved our lives by founding
Home Depot we're both stutterers here we
are posing with actress Emily Blunt at a
stuttering charity event if politicians
are giving money away
blanks partners would consider him
irresponsible not to take it the problem
is the politicians giving away your
money I get why they do it they like
going to games like telling voters
I brought a team to our town here's the
mayor of Las Vegas we are so ready for
major league sports in this town she and
her political buddies funneled 700
million tax dollars to the owners of the
Oakland Raiders to get them to move the
Raiders to Vegas watch the politicians
applaud themselves well the governor
signs the bills I'm glad this reporter
put this question to the mayor why
should there be one cent of public money
when you have two guys who could pay for
this
so I think it really is a benefit to us
that really could spill over into
something spill over into something
politicians always claim giving taxpayer
money to rich team owners will spill
over to everybody and yes the
well-connected people who pose with the
shovels and groundbreaking ceremonies do
collect some of what spills but the way
they justify the cost of taxpayers is
bunk this was a terrific investment they
always call stadium subsidies good
investments but it's not a good
investment
it's a bad one politicians teams and
stadium promoters all highlight this
extra business activity that occurs when
the football team plays at home but this
happens fewer than a dozen days a year
the stadium's also used for some
concerts and soccer games but most days
not much happens here economists who
study stadium subsidies say little or
none of the money makes it back to
taxpayers the problem is the scene
versus the unseen we see the people at
the games and extra customers and some
businesses on game days stadium
promoters show us this but looking at
this means we miss the unseen cost the
unseen cost is that those people would
otherwise be spending their money
elsewhere in the local communities at
the local bar there's one less bartender
there was one less waitress hired
another restaurant a movie theater that
had one less theater full right a
thousand little cuts but those ordinary
businesses don't have the clout that the
big boys have welcome to Super Bowl 53
so Sunday when Atlanta politicians brag
about their stadium we
Lanta and clueless media claimed this
created job who or a thousand jobs
created to do this let's also remember
all the jobs they destroyed and the
taxpayer money they squander